[Music]
this is deepmind
the podcast and I'm Hannah fry over the
last year I have been getting an inside
look at current research into artificial
intelligence or AI and we've been
talking to scientists researchers and
engineers about how things stand and
where we headed tracing the fast-moving
story of one of the biggest challenges
in science today so if you want to be
inspired on your own AI journey then
you've come to the right place
up until now in this series we have
largely looked at what AI is capable of
in the lab or in the world of games but
the ambition of people working in AI is
to help solve problems in the real world
right now people are trying to use AI to
help with everything from predicting
traffic jams to monitoring endangered
species and here at deepmind they've
also been working on a few things
now we could call them case studies but
where would the fun be in that so I'll
tell you what let's one of those big
trailer things shall we in this episode
we learn how a I might potentially help
save the sight of thousands of eye
disease sufferers we get the output from
the first neural network and we can
interrogate that as doctors and making
decisions for our patients help break
down the Enigma of protein folding we
can learn what the processes or a
description of the process so that we
can take a sequence and then predict its
structure an impact on our growing
energy demands if that waste he isn't
taken care of somehow it will literally
melt your laptop
first I want you to meet Sims with a
spoon Sims is originally from South
Carolina she's now the program manager
at deepmind and she is a big believer in
the potential benefits that AI can bring
when people think about deep mine if
they think about games they're largely
thinking about the research side but
trying to solve for intelligence is
literally to use that intelligence to
make the world a better place the world
has no shortage of problems we need to
solve we've got some really big ones
some smaller ones but for the areas of
immense complexity things where there's
lots of data and lots of permutations or
a huge combinatorial space of
possibilities sometimes that's really
daunting for human brains to try to
figure out stuff in the real others just
really complicated yeah it's really
complicated and you know real-world data
is really messy but if we can use AI to
try to find a path through that
complexity then we can solve our
problems faster than we could if we were
trying to do it on our own nowhere is
that more true than in medicine in 2016
deepmind partnered up with Moorfields
Eye Hospital NHS Foundation Trust in
London to try and apply deep learning to
AI scans with the number of people
suffering from sight loss in the UK set
to double by 2050 the trial had the
potential to be hugely impactful peers
keen is a consultant ophthalmologist at
Moorfields Eye Hospital and National
Institute for Health Research and knows
firsthand about the demands placed on
doctors one of the huge problems that we
have in ophthalmology not just in the UK
but all around the world is the huge
number of patients that we have to deal
with so in particular and the National
Health Service we get nearly 10 million
clinic appointments in the UK every year
and that's actually 10% of all clinic
appointments across the whole NHS and
it's a number that's increased by more
than 1/3 in the past 5 years why is it
increase so I think it's increased
because of the ageing population
I think it's increased because certain
diseases like diabetes are on the rise
and so we just have to deal with a lot
of eye problems related to that so for
example I can tell you about just one
condition which is age related macular
degeneration or AMD and AMD is the
commonest cause of blindness in the UK
comas cause of blindness in Europe and
and in North America as well and for
just that one condition nearly 200
people developed the blinding forms of
AMD every single day just in the UK and
so the challenge that we have is that
those people have to be seen and treated
in an urgent fashion the problem then is
that in for example in 2016
Moorfields Eye Hospital in London where
I work received 7,000 urgent referrals
from the community as possible wet AMD
the blinding form of this condition but
after 7,000 referrals only 800 patients
actually had the severe form of the
disease with so many people getting
urgent referrals is inevitable that
patients are gonna have to wait weeks to
be seen by a specialist and during that
time you have thousands of people who
think they've got an eye disease that
will threaten their sight who don't
actually need to worry and hundreds of
people with a curable condition whose
sight could be saved but is slipping
away while they wait peers told me about
one of his patients Alain Mona Alain
lost her sight from macular degeneration
in her left eye completely more than 10
years ago before there was good
treatment and in 2013 she started to
develop blurring a vision in her good
eye she went to her High Street
optometrist who looked into her eye and
said I think you're developing AMD in
your good eye you need to be seen and
treated urgently because now we have
good treatments for this she got an
appointment to another hospital in the
NHS and it was six weeks later so can
you imagine if you were at home and
you're losing your sight and your good
eye and you're told you have to wait six
weeks when there is a treatment that's
available and if that was my family
member
I'm treated in six days not in six weeks
here is where the AI comes in and the
idea is simple patients who are referred
to more fields will already have had
pictures taken of the back of their eye
by their doctor or the optometrist in
their high street opticians these are
two and three-dimensional images known
as Oct scans that can show up any one of
50 different diseases if you can use
artificial intelligence to filter
through those images first and triage
the patients you can flag the people
with a serious disease get them in front
of a doctor sooner give them an earlier
diagnosis earlier treatment and
potentially save their site before
artificial intelligence and before the
sick sent recent successes of deep
learning the traditional approach to
programming an algorithm to recognize a
photo of a cat for example would be you
would write all that code to describe
the features of a cat cat has whiskers
cat as a tail then you'd say some cats
don't have a tail some cats don't have
fur etc etc and you try and write
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
lines of code to describe that with deep
learning we don't do that with deep
learning we show many examples often
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
pictures of cats - a neural network and
it will extract the features of interest
itself and learn how to recognize a cat
well we simply do the same thing but
with eye diseases the Machine doesn't
care whether it's looking at cats or the
backs of eyes yeah to a large extent yes
and I think the reason why this
collaboration has been successful so far
is because Moorfields Eye Hospital is
one of the oldest one of the largest AI
hospitals in the world and we have huge
numbers of O CT scans to train these
neural networks does it work then I
think the results are amazing I think
they're they're jaw-dropping I think
that the algorithm we've created is on a
par with world-leading experts at
Moorfields
in triaging these are CT scans
but there is quite a big difference
between spotting cats in pictures and
picking out eye disease for something so
important how do you know the algorithm
is getting it right
how can a consultant be sure to see what
the algorithm saw or feel confident to
overrule it if they don't agree
well the key has told me is about
building an AI that doesn't just tell
you what it's found but also shows you
and to do that the AI needs not one
neural network but two so the first
neural network is trained to identify
all the disease features on the scan and
the second neural network is trained to
take those disease features and to use
them to make a diagnosis on the skin so
it's first going through and kind of
highlighting areas that don't look
totally normal yeah anything that looks
suspicious yeah the second ones coming
in explaining what's going on and all of
those and using that to come to a final
decision exactly yeah and you can see
all those areas that that first neural
network has highlighted yes so that's
one of the great advantages of this
approach we get the output from the
first neural network and we can
interrogate that as doctors making
decisions for our patients so if you've
got bleeding in the retina or if you've
got leakage of fluid and water logging
of the retina it will highlight all of
those features so if you see that a
patient has diabetic eye disease then
you can see the very typical features
that have led it to make that decision
which gives a lot of I think reassurance
for healthcare professionals who would
be using this there's a double whammy
with this approach not only can it
reassure the consultants helping them
with the diagnosis they're already doing
but there is hope that the AI might one
day also be able to advance our
understanding of the eye itself in 2018
another group of researchers decided to
see if they could use deep learning on
images of the retina to predict the sex
of the patient now the best an eye
doctor could manage would be a 50-50
guess
but to their astonishment the algorithm
got 97% right
no ophthalmologist in the world has any
idea what it is that this algorithm is
picking up on in a photograph or any
theory as to why the male and female I
might be structurally different but the
AI has found something that they're now
trying to understand and in the more
field study even when the algorithm gets
the diagnosis wrong it might still be
picking up on something that the
professionals hadn't spotted what was
interesting was that when we looked at
the cases that the algorithm got wrong
we actually had to take a step back
because it seemed like some of those
cases were very ambiguous challenging
cases where maybe the algorithm had made
the right answer and our gold standard
was at least open to debate
really so really kind of like jaw
dropping there at the results that we
were getting jaw dropping indeed so
that's AI dipping its toe into the world
of medicine but how about one of the
most fundamental problems in science
when I spoke to a very senior researcher
about what he thought were the most
significant problems in biology he his
top problem was understanding the brain
and how that works
his second problem that he thought was
the most important was understanding how
proteins fold this is sandy Nelson a
product manager for deep mind science
program and as sandy told me it's hard
to overstate the importance of proteins
it is the most cited topic in 50 million
scientific papers so many of the terms
are used to query thinking about medical
conditions are actually underlying
proteins so we think about the immune
system how that works of all that's
proteins we think about hormones we know
that regulates so many functions in our
body so of course drugs are a lot to do
about small molecules interacting with
proteins but there's many other ways
which proteins are important for
thinking about say disease
so we know for example Alzheimer's and
some of those neurodegenerative diseases
are to do proteins or proteins are
implied
proteins are the building blocks of all
living systems stretched out straights
they're just big long chains of amino
acids a bit like a ribbon but they fold
in on themselves and make these giant
three-dimensional structures stuck
together with peptide bonds now the
number of different ways a protein could
fold is vast think origami here except
mind-bogglingly complicated human
microbiological origami with 10 to the
power of 300 possibilities and
scientists care a great deal about
exactly what shape those final folded
proteins end up as part of the reason
the proteins are so useful for taking
part in so by cat many biochemical
processes because they are specific they
can target very very specific points in
some process that specificity comes from
the uniqueness of their shape so when we
think about proteins are the the go-to
molecule for anything you need to do in
a living animal if you want to try and
understand why some of the proteins have
gone wrong or to create some kind of
intervention understanding that process
of creating structure from sequence is a
first step and maybe designing proteins
or understanding why it might go wrong
the function of the protein whether it
is to detect light in the eye or fight
disease or speed up reaction rates is
determined by its unique
three-dimensional structure the question
is how does the protein go from one
state to the other from the ribbon to
the final folded structure what is the
objective heaven is it that in the end
you want to create something where I
tell you a sequence of amino acids and
you tell me what the structure will look
like so it is simplest level yes if you
could do it as accurately as it can be
done in a lab that says huge amount of
effort in theory you can just observe
the shape of the final folded structure
the most common way of doing this is by
bombarding crystals of the protein with
x-rays
inferring its shape from the way that
these beams are scattered but that is
hard to do it can cost hundreds of
thousands of dollars for each protein
structure and take months or even years
of work it's so hard in fact that max
Peretz won a Nobel Prize in 1962 just
for figuring it out for one single
protein hemoglobin there is an
alternative though the final structure
of the protein is actually determined by
the chain of component parts the forces
and charges that are acting on each of
those individual amino acids so in
theory you could use the physics to
predict how the protein ribbon is going
to fold but it's going to take a lot of
number crunching so if you had a
gigantic enough computers you know
supercomputer level I could give you a
string of amino acids and you could tell
me what shape it would end up as but the
problem is that we just don't have the
computing power to crunch through it not
at the level of modeling all the forces
so we can explain why the protein folds
the way it does using our understanding
of chemistry and physics but because of
the size and the complexity of the
molecules there are so many forces we
can't model everything and here's where
AI comes into it we think that there's a
another level of abstraction where we we
think we can maybe find a summary
description of all those forces and
that's again too hard to come at through
analysis but maybe we can learn that
because we've got a huge data set which
says well this sequence folds this way
and we know that that's reliably the
case so using machine learning maybe we
can learn what the processes or a
description of the process so that we
can take a sequence and then predict its
structure
here is a problem with a very clear
objective correctly predict how a chain
of amino acids is going to fold and a
vast vast number of possible ways to get
there ai is perfectly placed to cut
through that complexity the only problem
is that even with AI on your side these
things are so enormous ly complicated
that you still can't cut a clear path to
predicting how a protein might fold
based only on the physics thankfully
though there is a trick that you can use
to simplify the problem and give your AI
a head start the facts that proteins are
so diverse can help you constrain the
problem although I should warn you as a
mathematician I found this stuff pretty
hard to get my head around so I'm going
to try and walk you through it nice and
slowly proteins like organisms have a
long evolutionary history they can
sometimes be small random mutations in
the string of amino acids every now and
then a mutant protein will differ from
its normal version on just one of its
corners where if you unraveled it back
into the ribbon of amino acids the
markers of that mutation would show up
in more than one spot you can imagine
this as though you've got your folded
ribbon scrunched up in some complicated
shape in your hand and then you take a
felt-tip pen to one corner of it now if
you unfolded your ribbon and flattened
it out you would see that the pen would
have stained various spots along its
length so working backwards then if you
start with a flattened ribbon and notice
something strange in a few different
places marks that hint a consistent
mutation you know that however the
protein ends up being folded you found a
big clue those stains must have to be
next to each other in the final protein
collect up all of those clues and you
have greatly simplified your problem is
it like you've got this this vow
just sort of landscape of options and
you're trying to build walls to pen
yourself in yes that's exactly right
because these proteins are so large they
could fold in so many different shapes
so we need to find clues that allow us
to eliminate whole mass of shapes so we
can concentrate just on a much smaller
number you're making the problem smaller
that's right you're listening to a
podcast from the people at deep mind now
every two years there is a big protein
folding competition called CASP critical
assessment of structure prediction
competition over the course of three
months academics from around the world
compete to predict the structures of
amino acids using algorithms the
structures of these particular amino
acids have already been confirmed
through traditional observation so it's
possible to judge who comes closest and
in 2018 deepmind entered it's AI program
alphago and we had to look at how other
people did protein folding and we saw
how they used evolutionary information
and what other people had been doing was
they'd been looking at a sort of binary
constraint we said these two amino acids
should be in contact shouldn't be in
contact
whereas what deepmind did is we looked
at the probability of different
distances between those amino acids so
that's really like just saying well we
tried to retain some more information or
learn a better function for describing
that relationship between proximity of
amino acids so in terms of the fences
that you're building on your landscape
I'm not going quite far with this
knowledge you were making sure that you
weren't throwing away any information
that's why our fences were more subtly
defined or a bit more clearly delineated
or they were less fence like and more
like just a sort of that's right nice
but that actually ended up making the
prediction more accurate yes that's
right so it's it's a very very
complicated function but we
were able to learn that and so once we
were able to learn to kind of
essentially retain that extra
information that's one of the key things
that made our system more successful
[Music]
with the problem reduced the a I could
get to work doing what it does best for
three nail-biting months the deep mind
alpha fall team worked on the
competition
turning sequences of amino acids into
predictions of three-dimensional folded
shapes we didn't have any strong signal
which told us how well we're performing
we could see that we were not perfect in
many cases so it is very hard to find
out how well we were doing compared to
other people there are so many fantastic
researchers that were publishing great
results until we actually went through
that sort of organized assessment very
very hard to really figure out how well
we were doing
and then finally it was the moment of
truth of the 43 strings of amino acids
they were given the team came closest to
correctly predicting the structure for
25 of them the team that came in second
only managed three a staggering result
by anyone's standards you're kind of
downplaying this because I was talking
to a few academics when this this result
came out and of all of the results that
have come out of deepmind this is the
one that's got the scientific community
most excited yes and and that's because
this is a classical scientific domain
it's a grand challenge in science that
many people have worked on so it's
something that many many scientists care
about deeply they can see what the
potential impact is and it's been known
to be a very hard problem so we've been
able to make a step change on a hard
problem that's been worked on for over
50 years in terms of interventions then
is this just something that biologists
and scientists will get very excited
about in terms of kind of blue sky
research understanding protein or is it
something that could end up having an
impact in real people's lives so I guess
it's similar to all sort of biomedical
research it's fundamental so it has huge
leverage of essentially will affect many
many things but it needs to be
translated into something specific for
it to have immediate impact and on
people's lives so for example if we
think about the drug discovery process
part of that process goes on in labs and
it's very abstract and all to do with
chemistry but ultimately that process
does produce medicines that we can buy
or prescribe which ultimately will
affect our lives so this is at the start
early part of that process for example
although the long-term implications of
protein folding have the potential to
impact all of us it's not exactly a
topic that most of us are coming
face-to-face with on a daily basis but
one issue that we are all facing is that
of climate change
you remember Simms who met earlier while
her team decided to focus their efforts
on one specific climate challenge energy
consumption in data storage and they
started its by looking for a place where
burning far more energy than we need to
because it turns out your emails are one
of the things that are warming the
planet if you think about the things
that we all do online every day whether
that's sending an email doing a Google
search looking at dog videos on YouTube
you know the number one videos cat
videos for me it's dog videos I make I
make nice-nice all of that requires
compute power and you know the
information that we you know data we
send data that we store when information
is disseminated all of that runs through
a physical space ie the data center it
and it takes a lot of energy to do all
of those actions that we rely on on the
internet because there I mean there are
actual sort of physical warehouses that
are holding all of those cat videos o as
there yes they are physical spaces and
if you think about the amount of energy
they consume a data center you know in a
large industrial kind of setting can
consume the same amount of energy as a
small town I mean these things are
massive and they require a lot of energy
to run they also require a lot of energy
to cool all those emails sitting in your
Inbox the four dog videos you're
streaming simultaneously the request you
sent to the server to download this very
podcast every one of those things
requires computing power in a data
center somewhere collectively
data centers now use 3% of the world's
energy the equivalent of a whole new
country that just popped up on the map a
few years ago and all that computing
generates heat lots and lots of heat if
you imagine how hot your laptop
gets when you're streaming Netflix or
you know the for video is online imagine
that but multiply it times a million
what if that waste heat isn't taken care
of somehow it will literally melt your
laptop or in the case of the data center
it will melt your server that's why your
laptop has a fan
that's why data centers have cooling
that needs to happen there we have to
keep them at a temperature so they don't
melt and you and I can get our dog
videos off YouTube and I guess just
cooling down those data centers takes up
at a vast amount of energy yes it does
we are you know we're talking about
chillers required that are the size of
buses in order to to keep them cool and
this is where a eye comes in so imagine
you were trying to control the cooling
of a data center and a human being who
you know it's usually a facility manager
data center operator just has to kind of
dials to control and that was all you
had to do to control the entire Center
now that is a vast oversimplification
like a fine and a key yeah exactly
just those tips you could figure out the
the best you know is it just aircon is
it just fan is it both is it neither
like that's not that many options right
you could figure that out but when it
turns into a huge number of pieces of
equipment with set points on every
single one which are all things you can
change by some degree that then interact
all the sudden you've got a vast number
literally a number of options that is in
the billions and that's just too much
for a facility manager a data set
operator a human being to try to control
so this is where we think AI is it's the
perfect space for AI because AI can
adjust a vast amount of information more
than the human brain can and can help us
figure out which of those permutations
which of those combinations actually is
the optimal path forward
how does AI cut through one of this this
complexity
we can ask a model to figure out okay we
want to keep the data center at a
certain temperature but we want to use
less energy to do that here all of the
ways that you can manipulate the system
please figure it out the setting might
look quite different to a game of chess
or go but the principle ideas here are
exactly the same again you have a very
clear objective namely keep the center
cool while using as little energy as
possible and a vast vast number of
possibilities of how to get there that
the AI has to find a path through and
once it does the AI tells you how all of
the dials should be set across the
across the center exactly what's that
points to change and by how much to
change them and does it work it does
work that's the best part about it we
saw that with direct AI control ie you
know getting those recommendations and
having a I feed them directly back into
the physical infrastructure of the data
center going through lots of safety
constraints we saw a 30% reduction in
the amount of energy required to cool
Google data centers which is math which
is massive and a really exciting number
I don't have to confess I've seen the
graph yeah of what happened when you put
the AI in indirect control of all of the
dolls and it is staggering I mean you've
got this it's sort of bumpy line that
goes along about how much energy is
being used and then it's all it looks
like those graphs were the pound crashes
yeah she's in terrible news it drops off
a cliff and then you kind of have it
bumping along the bottom of the graph at
which point you take the AI away from
being in control and it says switch back
over to human control and just jump
straight back up to where it was before
it's amazing is the AI running the
cooling system in the day centers right
now yes it is which is fantastic and
hoping to roll them out to even more in
the future now that we've proved that
this works and works well with more data
with more practice in other words the AI
gets better over time so 30% is a
fantastic number but it's increasing you
know a rules and heuristics don't get
better over time but AI does that's the
best part about these systems
and that is why there is so much
excitement about a eyes potential here
at deep mind and AI labs around the
world if you would like to find out more
about applying AI to energy healthcare
and scientific problems or explore the
world of AI research beyond deep mind
you'll find plenty of useful links in
the show notes for each episode and if
there are stories or sources that you
think other listeners would find helpful
then let us know you can message us on
Twitter or email the team at podcast at
deep mind calm you can also use that
address to send us your questions or
feedback on the series now so we have
another break